How bad is my chance for lymphetema if I take out two or three more lymph nodes?
That would make 78 out total in the left armpit trying to decide if I should
stay on the hormonal suppressing drugs and do no surgery or do the surgery and
the drugs. Yeah, it's it's really difficult because we've had patients that have
had the 30 lymph nodes out and seemingly at least all the years we've spoken with
them seemingly have no issues with lymphetema and then we've had patients that
have gotten just a few lymph nodes out and can't get rid of the swelling in
their arms. I had one patient. Of course she was elderly and she's passed away.
She was in her late 80s at the time but she was a little spark plug and I think
she only had one axillary lymph. They'll take it out and my gosh her daughter could
not get the swelling down in her arm. She had to wear these tight bandages and
handed bandages or arm up when it was just horrific. So everybody's different on
how their how their lymph system is able to drain and how much you know a
demon that they have. You do have to think long term too because I know this
gal I think it was years before that she came to us that she actually had that
surgery and as you age you know you might have other comorbidities that are
causing a demon you know different imbalances and electrolytes and different you know
issues with your liver and your kidneys and your adrenal glands that you're
not expelling water correctly and and then that's what it might come back and
haunt you so that you have you're retaining more water and now it's more
difficult to get rid of it. So it's a difficult question to answer I wish I
could say oh if you only get this many out you're gonna be fine. It's just not
possible to give an honest assessment of that.